in just the past week house democrats
have voted to legalize abortion up until
a point of birth
spend three and a half trillion dollars
that we don't have to entrench their own
power
and make women sign up for the draft in
fairness to democrats on this last point
135 house republicans joined the
democrats in preparing america's
daughters to strap on combat boots the
bind administration has admitted to
releasing at least ten thousand illegal
aliens into the country in just the past
week
and that's the number they're admitting
so the real number is almost certainly
higher and even the liberal media are
admitting that the capital riot
supposedly the gravest insurrection in
u.s history was orchestrated at least in
part by the feds
i never believed the lying leftists or
the naive squishes who insisted that the
biden administration would govern in a
moderate way that it would represent
some kind of return to normalcy
but this degree of radicalism is
shocking to even the most hard-nosed
conservatives and the biggest gut punch
of all is how many self-styled
conservatives
are helping to push the agenda along i'm
michael nolsas the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from jeff the hokey
who says the border patrol needs to say
these aren't horses they identify as
cows wow what a genius
strategy because the biden
administration is now saying that the
border patrol can't can't use horses
even in the areas where the cars can't
get to they can't use horses because
they don't want them to actually arrest
the illegal aliens coming over so that's
fine they're not using horses they're
using cows they're using
they're using equine
beings that identify as volvos great
idea really good idea you know
when you want to protect the most basic
rights that we've got when you want to
protect the most basic right to life i
would strongly recommend you check out
40 days for life when the topic of
abortion comes up the left has a lot of
talking points some of them are morally
confused some of them are factually
confused they're just simply not true if
you are struggling on what to say or how
to say it when abortion is the topic of
the conversation you need to check out a
recent book it's called what to say when
the complete new guide to discussing
abortion since its release it has
already been a number one amazon new
release and a number two amazon
bestseller it's already on its second
printing it's an easy book to use tells
you what to say what not to say and its
proven arguments
have have worked with just about
everybody people on the fence abortion
supporters these arguments have even
worked
on planned parenthood workers
go check it out today what to say when
the complete new guide to discussing
abortion how to change minds and convert
hearts in a brave new world you can go
to amazon or you can get it directly
from 40 days for life
at 40daysforlife.com
with republicans like the ones we've got
who needs democrats who needs democrats
when you've got republicans who are
much more radically left-wing or much
more inclined to go along with radically
left-wing ideas than even the democrats
were five or ten years ago
key example here
the house of representatives just passed
a 768
billion defense bill this comes up all
the time it's the ndaa the national
defense authorization act and it's
always somewhat controversial because
it's very expensive and some of the
money is going to some wars that we're
in or some aspect of the military that
the liberals don't like or that the
conservatives don't like
okay that's fine and then they always
argue about it and then they end up
passing the ndaa every single time
this year was a little bit different
because this year the ndaa included a
requirement for women to register for
the military draft
181 democrats voted for this bill
okay i'm not surprised about that
the dem the logic of the democrats is
such that they are gonna make
women the daughters of the united states
sign up for the military draft be
drafted into war to go die
to to protect the men or so i don't know
i don't know what they're thinking but
the most scandalous and dispiriting part
of it
is that 135 republicans voted for this
as well this is absolutely
unacceptable absolutely unacceptable i
understand i have some sympathy for the
republicans who thought this is a tough
vote in my district they're going to run
ads saying i don't support the military
oh who cares it's not a big deal oh
women are going to have to sign up for
the draft but they probably won't be
drafted hey actually it's equality men
and women are exactly the same it's no
big deal don't it's a huge deal it's a
huge deal this is absolutely
unacceptable this is evidence of very
very poor judgment
on the part of these republicans
thankfully there were some republicans
who recognized this notably chip roy who
tends to be correct on a whole lot of
things chip roy explained why
despite the many
uh the many attractive features of
voting for this bill he just couldn't do
it
thank you jonathan louisiana thank the
chairman i thank my colleagues for
joining us here today
you're going to hear a lot over the next
coming days from our republican
colleagues about why we should all be
locked up in supporting the ndaa now
everybody here on this stage certainly
speaking for myself we support our men
and women in uniform i represent fort
sam houston i represent the army futures
command i represent about 80 000
veterans i stand alongside our men and
women in uniform whatever the pay raises
and whatever
material supplies
that they need in order to carry out
their job but what i do not support is
blindly supporting legislation
that is critically flawed at its core
because of oh we're in the minority
look right now today if you vote for the
ndaa you are voting to draft our
daughters
there is no other position you can take
the current law of the land does not
have a requirement that our daughters be
drafted
okay
if this ndaa is passed and signed into
law
then our daughters will be required
to sign up selective service and make
themselves available to the draft
that's it that's it
and so to me this is a line in the sand
and there are a lot of freedom caucus
members there with him you'll notice
marjorie taylor green is standing to his
right and i know people say well
marjorie greene she said kooky things
she she acts in sometimes an eccentric
way yeah that's sure that's totally true
i agree with that she has said kooky
things
at least marjorie taylor green
recognizes that it's unacceptable to
draft your daughters okay and a lot of
fancy republicans who went to really
fancy schools and they they're very
urban and they're very witty a lot of
them think it's perfectly fine to draft
your daughters so if you're asking me
who's the real kook here i'm i'm gonna
have to go with the people who who think
it's a good idea to make your the
daughters of america strap on combat
boots and actually i think margery green
is the reasonable one
here absolute this if you don't stand up
for this as a conservative i don't know
what you stand up for i don't know what
you
represent i don't know what your values
are
insane and by the way i've heard a line
of argument on this where they'll say
sometimes you'll hear this from kind of
cheeky conservatives they'll say look
the feminists want equality well that's
equality okay hey what we're going to
total look this is going to totally own
the libs because what's going to happen
is they said they wanted equality when
it comes to pay and when it comes to
certain political rights when it comes
to professional life but now they need
equality when they need to go get shot
at overseas that'll show them i don't
want to show them what come on but
that's what they wanted i don't care
what they wanted since when do i care
what feminists want since when do i care
what radical leftists want i don't i
care about what's right and wrong in our
public policy and this is wrong
and i don't think it's a wise idea to
give in to the libs on the thing that
they're clamoring for just to show them
down the line when our daughters are
being strafed by jihadis that it's a
that it's actually bad let's just stop
it right now let's just have some
spinal fortitude here and maybe some
other anatomical type of fortitude here
to say no
contrary to popular propaganda men and
women actually are different and a
nation that sends its women to war to
fight and die for the men is a sick
nation that's not just that's not right
at all
speaking of women's issues the house on
friday passed legislation that would
make
abortion a national right now i know
that abortion is already legal
at the national level but that's only
because the supreme court invented a
pretend imaginary constitutional right
to abortion in roe versus wade it was
affirmed in planned parenthood v casey
but it's not actually a law
so because now there are these wonderful
work around pro-life laws in texas
there's one coming up in florida they're
going to be others i hope
the house democrats passed a law
saying that
and look this this law is so
preposterous i don't see any way in
which it's upheld
unless of course the libs just really
clamp down on their power they throw
logic out the window which they have
been known to do before but
what they're saying is that now there's
a national right to an abortion
up until the moment of birth everywhere
in the country
okay
this is called the women's health
protection act it doesn't protect the
health of the female babies who are
being slaughtered
roughly half of the babies but it's the
women's health protection act it was
approved by the house 218 to 211 so this
at least was more of a party line vote
uh faces tough odds in the senate i
don't think it's going to go anywhere in
the senate but who knows you know it's
up in the air
the
the way that they're thinking about this
law is more interesting than the law
itself because
the measure states that health care
providers have a statutory right to
provide and patients a right to receive
abortion services without these
limitations okay so this is this is from
the bill
since 1973 the supreme court repeatedly
has recognized the constitutional right
to terminate a pregnancy before fetal
viability and to terminate a pregnancy
after fetal viability where it is
necessary when it's necessary in the
good faith medical judgment of in the
good faith judgment of someone whose job
it is to kill babies okay of the
treating healthcare professional for the
preservation of the life or health of
the person who is pregnant not of the
woman because it's not women anymore
it's the person who is pregnant the good
faith medical judgment of someone whose
job it is to kill babies i don't think
they have a lot of good faith
what this does in practice even though
it says there might be some limits on
that in practice it says there is no
limit because if the mother says you
know i might get a little depressed if i
have to have this baby then you can kill
the baby up till the moment of birth
second part many abortion specific
restrictions do not confer any health or
safety benefits on the patient well it
confers some benefits on one of the
patients namely the baby who's being
killed and third this is the the
craziest part
i know
that's uh saying quite a lot given how
crazy the rest of the bill is says
congress has the authority to enact this
act to protect abortion services
pursuant to a its powers under the
commerce clause of section 8 of article
1 and its powers under section 5 of the
14th amendment okay so the reason this
is so crazy is
congress should have no right to do this
this is not an interstate matter this
should be a matter for the states right
at least according to the commerce
clause but they're saying well because
abortion exists in multiple states it's
it's interstate commerce so we can
regulate it but then the craziest part
is they cite the 14th amendment equal
protection under the law what about the
equal protection of the babies actually
the 14th amendment makes a strong
argument for banning abortion nationwide
but they don't care this is the
radicalism that we are talking about
this would have been unthinkable in the
democratic party even i don't know four
or five years ago it would have been
unthinkable but that's how far the
country's moved to the left and they've
done it with some mild opposition from
republicans but largely they've done it
with the tepid support of the so-called
conservatives and republicans you know
when you want to protect your country
your community your life and your
identity especially your identity i
would strongly recommend you check out
lifelock do you feel safe when you're
browsing the internet
you should not you should if you if you
do feel safe if you don't realize
there's even a problem then you
especially should not okay
just to use one example payment apps
like venmo cash app and others they make
payments easy but
you might want to adjust those privacy
settings to prevent them from sharing
your personal information a recent
report found that payment apps share
user data with third parties including
banks fraud monitoring services some
even share it with marketing firms it's
very important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives every single day every second
almost of every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant cyber criminal could harm
what's yours your finances your credit
your reputation good thing there's
lifelock lifelock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats such as your
social security number for sale on the
dark web you've got access to a
dedicated restoration specialist if you
become a victim no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with lifelock by
norton join now save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com knowles
that's lifelock.com knowles for 25 off
there there's a really touching story
that's come out of new york and it's a
really touching story that i think shows
us
a new angle
on one of our biggest national problems
here's the story two newborn twins were
abandoned in an alleyway wrapped in
brown paper bags and killed in a rat
infested alleyway in the bronx really
really sad story
cops
found
the babies
they were new they just came out just
newborn babies abandoned in an alleyway
this does happen
more often than people would recognize
and so what the cops decide to do around
20 cops in new york
they
held a funeral for the babies they did
this at eternity funeral service in the
williamsbridge section of the bronx they
named the babies zeke and zane
zeke short for ezekiel means god's
strength zane means god's gift
and it was really beautiful ceremony
okay where these two two babies had a
funeral
not not by the parents obviously who
were degenerates and killers but by by
these cops
you know we're told the cops are very
evil you know and they're racist and
bigoted well this is a beautiful
beautiful scene
and one of the lieutenants says i've
never seen a case like this these were
two newborn babies who were full term
and then put in garbage bags and thrown
in a rat infested backyard their little
bodies had fractures this has weighed
heavy on every detective that has worked
on the case
wow yeah it's a it's a horrific case
horrific case but it's not particularly
horrific
the reason it's not particularly
horrific is that this happens
every single day in this country and it
doesn't just happen once a day in this
country it happens on average
2362 times each day
the little newborn baby
abandoned in the alleyway and killed
what do we say one day after birth maybe
on the day of his birth
if that baby
had been killed
a few hours earlier
that would have been not just tolerated
that would have been not just protected
by law that would have not just not just
been conducted in a medical facility
with some guy who has an md doing the
butchery it would have been lauded and
celebrated as a woman's right as
reproductive health is a beautiful
wonderful expression of liberty
and freedom and emancipation
and gender equality
if you want to think about the abortion
issue because i know that there are
apparently a lot more squishes in the
republican party and they're a lot
squishier even than i thought that they
were
just recognize that abortion is this
abortion is
it's not it's it's not even throwing
your kid into an alleyway in the bronx
it's worse than that at least those kids
got to breathe the air and live a little
life for i don't know an hour or so
with abortion it's you don't even get
that
you get
with with the true to to use a popular
phrase banality of evil you get a
medical doctor in a fluorescent lit room
performing the butchery to the adulation
and applause of the
population
really puts that in perspective 2 362
times per day
and the cops the cops can't get over
this these are you know this is their
job is to see
awful terrible things the underbelly of
society and they see this crime in
particular and they say oh my god this
is so heinous
that we're gonna we're gonna throw a
funeral for we're gonna actually take
our time and our money and go out and
recognize that we need some
ritual
mourning for this
that's how bad this crime is happens
almost 2 400 times a day speaking of
kids
the new york times
oh the new york times the new york times
has a kids section this is news to me i
do not read the new york times i don't
make a habit of that
fewer and fewer people read the new york
times each day so they have a kids
section and it's got a little cartoon of
a kid on there
and it says and by the way it's not a
kids section like it's for adults to
read about kids
it's the new york times for kids
you know adults don't read this section
it says what school is actually like
this year according to 29 kids who they
interviewed
and on the cover it's got this kid his
name is arnov alleged cartoon his name
is arnab he's 13. he's in pennsylvania
and the quote coming out of his mouth
says
i think the covid19 regulation should be
stricter cases are already rising
do you think that this is what the
students of america are saying
do you think no this is such pathetic
propaganda pravda in the soviet union
could not have done better could not
have done a more ridiculous job of
propaganda
it's like the new york times reports
from our nation's classrooms kids want
more homework
oh yes no we've been talking to all of
the kids and they want more homework and
they want
they don't want dessert or recess
anymore yes yes that's what our no i
don't think so i think the kids hate the
stupid masks i think they hate the vax
mandates and i think that they have in
many ways a justified resent of their
teachers and administrators and
even parents who are going along with
this stuff
okay but the new york times
just just showing the left-wing
impulse to exploit children for their
own
political gain and how heinous that is
i've called that out for a long time
called it out on television one time too
and the left doesn't like it when you
call them out on that sort of thing
now speaking of the new york times
uh the new york times has a
little piece out here that is probably
not going to be noticed by a lot of
people but it should be noticed because
it gives away the whole game
it's a piece acknowledging
that
on jan january 6 january 6th the worst
the worst insurrection in american
history
that
that event was
coordinated at least in part by the feds
do you remember there was the justice
for january 6th rally that happened a
week or two ago
and the only people who showed up were
the press
and undercover feds it was really the
fbi picnic is what i referred to it as
there were no actual people there you
know so here's the headline from the
times among those who marched into the
capital on january 6th an fbi informant
gee you don't say
you don't say i mean i we
anyone with two brain cells called this
basically from the very beginning they
said you know i bet the feds were
involved in this this seems like a total
setup a member of the far right proud
boys texted his fbi handler during the
assault
but maintained that the group had no
plan in advance to enter the capital and
disrupt the election certification
and you're seeing images come out now
videos of the way that the
alleged insurrectionists entered the
capital it was actually in many cases
somewhat orderly in many cases they were
actually led into the capital we know
that the the chief uh accusation against
the
capital rioters that day was that they
killed a cop it just didn't happen even
the new york times later had to admit
that that was a lie
so yes this is what happens
the feds do this sort of thing and to me
the story here is not that the new york
times is admitting this it's not that
the feds actually were involved in this
i think
sensible people already knew that to me
the real story is
what are they not telling us
if they're going to acknowledge this
degree of fed coordination
what are they not acknowledging what's
the next shoe to drop what's out there
it seems to me
that almost every not everything but
almost everything we were told about
january 6th uh was a lie was a lie and
just was not true
and speaking of that day
i've got to get to my absolute
what i say my favorite or my least
favorite of the squishy republicans the
squishy republican court
jester conservative par excellence
liz cheney
liz cheney just did an interview on 60
minutes now i will sum up
most of the interview
this is because it was a long interview
it touched on a broad array of topics
touched on oh my gosh touched on gay
marriage it touched on transgenderism it
touched on all these various issues the
the main thrust of the interview was was
this
the capital
january 6 right so that was basically
that you i just saved you a long time of
watching that interview but but just to
show you
how much further it goes than that they
then get to the question of marriage now
liz cheney very famously supports the
traditional definition of marriage the
definition of marriage that has existed
everywhere
at all times everywhere on earth
throughout all of human history
until about five minutes ago here in the
west
now liz cheney says
absolutely not
she was wrong your sister's gay she's
married she has children
and in 2013
you came out against same-sex marriage
while your father went the other way
and it was looked upon as courageous
when he did that
how do you defend what you did i was
wrong
um i was wrong
i love my sister very much
i
love
her family very much
and uh
and and i was wrong
it's a it's a very personal issue and
very personal for my family
i
believe that my dad was right
and my sister and i have had that
conversation
i was not expecting that
you weren't expecting that i'm i'm
waiting for her to adopt every other
live position too what liz cheney did
just here is
is so much worse than just changing her
position on this issue
because
she is
she is implicitly not so implicitly
condemning republicans for holding
the normal view on this issue that
everyone's held everywhere else it's
just just one more it's
one more bit of evidence that the
republican party is rotten to
the core which we'll get to in one
second first though you gotta check out
ben's show today
ben's gonna be talking about how biden's
got all these awful budgetary issues his
awful slander against the border patrol
also you got to subscribe and start
listening to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to your
podcast leave a five star review if you
like what you hear we'll be right back
with a lot more
liz cheney just came out on 60 minutes
to say she was wrong about redefining
marriage that when she's she opposed
redefining marriage to include same-sex
uh
monogamous unions
her father even supported redefining
marriage and you know it was a
contentious issue in the republican
party and her sister is a lesbian and so
this is that complicates things and she
just said i was wrong i was wrong i love
my sister this is personal i was so
wrong me i culpa me a culpa me a maxima
culpa this is so much worse
than just advocating for defining
marriage because what what liz cheney is
doing here is buying into the lie
that people who believe that sexual
difference has something to do with
marriage maybe a lot to do with marriage
are somehow
irrational or bigoted this is so much
worse than saying look we have a
difference of opinion on this i think
even though marriage has always meant
one thing i think we should radically
redefine marriage and here are my
reasons why and i understand that you
have your reasons why but here's why i
think i'm right what she's saying is no
i was wrong oh i was so wrong my dad was
right i i love my sister and what i did
was implicitly she's saying what i did
was hateful toward my sister it was
cruel to my sister it's not
it's not
opposition to gay marriage or you know
same-sex marriage or redefining marriage
is not
grounded in people hating gay people or
an irrational animus as some judges have
said
it's it's based on a simple conviction
held by all people everywhere that
marriage as an institution whatever it's
going to mean in whatever social con
context with polygamy even in some
cultures or without polygamy or with the
toleration of divorce or without the
toleration of divorce whatever variation
on it you're going to say that sexual
difference the difference between men
and women has something to do with that
okay that's not irrational that's not
bigoted that's not hateful that is
quite simple and quite obvious if you
ask me
now there's this new idea that has
arisen in the last 40 50 years very
slowly that men and women are not
different than men and women are
for all intents and purposes exactly the
same and so as a result of that logic
you get movements like second wave
feminism you get movements like the gay
marriage movement and you get movements
like transgenderism
and i see how those movements arise out
of the claim that men and women are
exactly the same
but
we disagree with that claim and it's not
hateful and it's not bigoted and it's
certainly not irrational to pretend that
men and women or to acknowledge that men
and women are not the same frankly i
think it's irrational to suggest that
they are the same okay
so liz cheney has not just changed her
opinion on a political issue she has
gutted the the central core
of
of
in any way
reasonably conservative view of of the
world and she is smearing her fellow
republicans as she has wanted to do but
she goes even further by the way
at least she has the integrity to go
further she she follows this radical
idea to its radical conclusion which is
she seems to be upset that republicans
are not embracing radical transgender
ideology too
you know this this is an issue that um
we have to recognize uh you know as as
human beings that
we need to work against discrimination
uh of all kinds uh in our country in our
state
we were at an event a few nights ago and
and uh there was a young woman who said
she doesn't feel safe
sometimes uh because she's transgender
and nobody should feel unsafe
freedom means freedom for everybody
what does anybody understand what that
word salad means she goes we need to
fight describe all forms of
discrimination
including transgender discrimination
because some people feel unsafe whatever
that i don't have no idea what that
means they feel unsafe and that's why we
need to abolish the legal distinction
between men and women and let men go
into the women's bathroom what about the
women who feel unsafe when men go into
their bathroom what about the little
girls who are at the changing room at
the public pool who feel unsafe when
grown men walk in there well but the but
the grown men feel like women
and and they are women and we need to
freedom means freedom forever what about
the freedom of the little girl to not
change in front of a grown dude what
about that freedom is that a freedom no
it's only freedom in the liberal
leftist direction
this is
this behold your principled republicans
this is what we're told that the liz
cheney's of the world
and the squishes the squish caucus
they are the principled dignified
republicans
in the traditional republic not this
crazy
irrational trump kind of republican way
they're the rational ones who think that
men and women are exactly the same
they're the rational ones who spend all
of their time attacking fellow
republicans and they're the rational
ones who are stumping for joe freaking
biden the most radical presidential
administration we've ever had in our
country's history because they're so
dignified and rational they're the true
conservatives
with
republicans like this woman
and the people who support her
we don't need democrats
we don't need them there's no different
it's like men and women are the same
republicans and democrats are the same
when you look at people like this woman
pathetic and
you'll always hear that it's it's the
margaery greens of the world who are the
kooks they're the threat to the republic
uh i don't know at least at least
marjorie greene recognizes we shouldn't
draft women
right liz cheney by the way voted for
that wrote voted to draft women of
course she did of course she did she
just admitted there's no difference
between men and women in her view
her mistaken view
pathetic stuff
pathetic stuff this is uh
to use a phrase from ronald reagan this
is a time for choosing folks
which way western man which way american
are we going to go the liz cheney route
or are we going to
preserve any semblance
of political opposition to radical
liberal agendas
gensake
speaking of feckless republicans jensaki
is accusing republicans of not offering
any solutions
to the immigration crisis yeah they're
really good at criticizing joe biden
over the border but what are their
solutions there are a lot of republicans
out there giving speeches about how
outraged they are about the situation at
the border not many who are putting
forward
solutions or steps that we could take so
we're a little tired of the speeches
we'd like to partner on solutions and
working together to address this problem
that has not been partisan in the past
and where are your solutions republicans
what come on give me one name me one
okay build the wall
uh
okay well give me two um all right uh
deport the illegal aliens
uh okay republicans well give me three
um
stop giving them government ids stop
giving them
government benefits tax their
remittances maybe even revoke birthright
citizenship maybe defund sanctuary
cities and sanctuary states maybe
require refugees to apply for asylum in
the first safe country that they enter
rather than just going through those
countries to the united states i don't
know how many more what is that that's
like seven eight
concrete policy ideas how many more do
you want
well what you just don't give me a real
one though guys come on give me i think
we're the only people who are proposing
any solution to the border and i think
the people who are not proposing
solutions are the democrats and they're
doing so not
merely because they're incompetent
but because they don't want to solve the
problem at the border
actually
the open border is their solution it's a
solution to a political problem that
americans don't want these foreign
nationals flooding over here among other
aspects of their radical agenda so the
solution is flood the country with
people who are much more likely to vote
for us
total projection as is often the case
the left will accuse the right of the
things that the left is doing
the the most transparent example of this
is colluding with the russians right
the left spent 100 years in this country
just about colluding with the russians
so let's let's be fair let's call it i
don't know 70 80 years taking the side
of the communists in russia and then
then
2016 rolls around they say the
republicans are colluding with the
russians you're you're the ones you're
the people
and actually really it does go up to 100
years you remember the russian reset
from hillary clinton do you remember
barack obama making a shady deal that
was caught on a hot mic saying don't
worry i'm going to go soft on russia
just i just got to get through my
election i got to lie to the american
people so it is it does go almost
exactly 100 years
but you republicans are colluding they
do this all the time
and they're doing it here you have no
solutions on immigration we're the only
people with solutions
i just rattled off
just here very quickly in the show seven
eight solutions
i got if you gave me
10 more minutes i could probably give
you another half dozen solutions but
they don't want
any of them
and and they're deflecting not just on
what are our solutions they're
deflecting even on joe biden
acknowledging the problem peter ducey
or they're one of one of the few
journalists remaining in america asks
jinsaki hey is the president you know at
the midst of this intense border crisis
is he considered like going down there
and looking at it
why hasn't president biden ever visited
the southern border
what would you like him to do at the
southern border and what impact do you
think that would have on the policies
why doesn't he want to go
i don't think it's an issue of wanting
to go i think it's an issue of what's
most constructive to address what we see
as a challenging situation at the border
in a broken immigration system and his
view is the most constructive role we
can play is by helping to push
immigration for uh reform forward
helping reform the broken policies of
the last several years uh and listening
to his team of advisors who have been to
the border multiple times about what the
path forward should look like why is
this the one crisis then that he thinks
he can manage better from here without
having seen it than going to the
southern border i can assure you the
president is well aware of what the
challenges are in our broken immigration
system something he watched closely over
the last four years so he's watched this
problem closely for the past four years
that's not quite true
it's partially true he's actually
watched this problem closely for the
last 50 years
joe biden has been in the government
at the national level
now for almost exactly 50 years
and
the problem has gotten worse and worse
and worse and worse as have most
problems since joe biden has been in
office in the senate than the vice
president now
apparently the president we don't see
him very much
so he's not going to go down there
he he knows he knows what we need to do
okay what is it what you just said you
don't have any answers and then you
tried to deflect and said the
republicans don't have any answers he's
not going down there because he's
trapped between a rock and a hard place
the
radical left-wing base
the the arch progressives want to keep
the border open because they hate
america and they don't think america
deserves to be a nation
the democratic operatives want to keep
the border open because they think
they're flooding the country with their
future voters and very likely they're
right depending on which country we're
talking about
and
then you've got the more moderate types
who broke for biden in some places they
want to seal up the border
but he can't appease both of those
groups so he's going to
or all three of those groups so he's
going to back away this is why he gave
kamala harris control over the border do
you remember it was one of the most
vicious things i've ever seen a
president do to a vice president he said
you're in charge of this now he's
setting her up completely for failure
because obviously those two do not like
each other very much she opened her
presidential campaign by accusing joe
biden being a racist okay i don't think
there's any love lost between those two
and what does joe what has kamala harris
done she hasn't gone down there either
because the democrats are
intrinsically incapable of solving the
problem at the border
because the incentives are too screwed
up they can't they can't possibly do it
mo
all of the incentives are aligned for
them to do nothing and and
inasmuch as there is an incentive to do
one thing or the other it's to keep the
border even more wide open
so there's there is nothing that a
democrat can do
on this particular
issue meanwhile you know things are bad
because the administration is admitting
that they're releasing 10 at least 10
000 illegal aliens just last week
into the interior of the country of the
17
400 that weren't deported back or didn't
return on their own to mexico how many
of them either
well first how many have been released
into the u.s uh they're released on
conditions and approximately i think
it's about 10
000 or so 12 000 have been released yes
and of the 5 000 that are still in
process
we will uh make determinations whether
they will be uh returned uh to uh haiti
uh based on our public health and public
interest
authorities
so are we talking about a total of 12
000 or could it be even higher it could
it could be even higher the number that
a return could be even higher what we do
is we follow the law as congress has
passed it
so
that's the most egregious lie we've
heard all show what we do is follow the
no if you followed the law you'd deport
all of these people but you're not
you're not following the law at all you
would enforce the law you wouldn't
punish your border patrol for enforcing
the law
i love i i actually love this question
from chris wallace he says how many
people majorcas the head of homeland
security says 10 to 12 000.
chris wall says that's the total 10 to
12 000 or could it be a little higher
well yeah it could be a little higher
it's just like the new york times saying
yeah there were some feds involved in
january 6.
if if the head of biden's dhs is telling
us that he released 10 to 12 000 into
the interior of the country you know
that the real number is much
much higher than that probably multiples
higher than that
speaking of numbers
the democrats in addition to drafting
women into the military with the help of
republicans and in addition to
legalizing or attempting to legalize
abortion up until the moment of birth
nationwide
they're also about to spend three and a
half trillion dollars on some budget
madness
this is an unpopular type of bill but
it's so
it's so
complicated that people probably are not
going to be paying a ton of close
attention to it it used to be that when
congress would pass bills they were
relatively narrow bills and they would
pass a lot of them
but now because congress doesn't really
govern in a particularly direct way they
they just give a lot of money to the
executive agencies and then the agencies
create all the rules that govern us
you know all the alphabet agencies and
all those the fda and the osha and all
of these various regulatory groups
so what
what they do is they just pass one big
bill so this is one of these gigantic
omnibus bills
it's a 3.5 trillion dollar budget
bill pelosi asked about this on abc and
she gave an answer that is
shocking to many but i actually think it
was brilliant she said
don't worry about the numbers worry
about
the values
this will be paid for so when some say
oh well what about inflation it will be
paid for and that's the the beauty of it
by having those in our our
economy and society who have not paid
their fair share paying their fair share
so again
the senate and the house those who are
not in full agreement with the
president's right let's see what our
value let's not talk about numbers
that's on dollars let's talk about
values
so when she says that the bill's paid
for that's just a lie i mean that's
that's preposterous not not even the
rosiest sort of optimism on on the way
these numbers are going to shake out
will will suggest that it's it's paid
for but put that aside for a second
that's just typical
left-wing lying about budget bills
what she says here
let's see what our values let's not talk
about numbers and dollars let's talk
about values that is brilliant and that
is right and republicans should take
notes republicans lawmakers
especially the confused ones that just
voted to draft women take out your pen
watch nancy pelosi
take some notes you should not be
talking about numbers and dollars and
cents you should be talking about values
the the republicans who went along with
that
defense authorization act
i know what they were thinking they were
thinking well
look general overall 99 of this defense
bill is fine and you know the numbers
shake out pretty well and we got to pay
our troops and we don't want to be
accused of not giving a raise to our
troops and that won't look good and then
i might dip in the polls for a little
bit and that might not be nice and there
will be a campaign that you're thinking
in dollars and cents folks think in
values
think in values if the situation had
been reversed
right i know this is a silly
hypothetical
and it's an overused one but i actually
think it's kind of illuminating here
if the situation had been reversed i
think what the democrats would have done
is they would have renamed this national
defense authorization act they would
have renamed it the draft women make
women die in combat act and they would
go on tv and they would and they would
have the protection of the mainstream
media and they would say yeah
republicans are trying to make us vote
for the make women die in combat act and
we think that's a bad idea so we're
going to oppose it and they would have
made the battle about values about right
and wrong about justice they wouldn't
have made it about the little itty bitty
details of the defense authorization
bill and raising the money here and this
and that would have made it about values
and they would have won but we don't win
because we don't understand that because
you've got the left which is offering an
actual moral it's an immoral vision for
the country but it it involves moral
arguments and then you've got
some right wingers i we try to do it on
this show who try to put politics in
those terms as well
and then you've got pro i would say
probably the majority of elected
republicans not the majority of
republican voters but the majority of
elected republicans
who just think in these utilitarian
terms like eggheads with a spreadsheet
who say well actually you know but if we
cut taxes that it'll increase receipts
to the federal government but actually
who cares who cares i don't care about
that
i don't care about that
when the actual business of the
government right now is sending women
into freaking combat you idiots
you
myopic
narrow-minded
materialist
craven idiots
i can't democrats would not have made
this mistake isn't it i don't even know
if it's a mistake you want to talk about
values before we go i have to get to
this
pita
pita the people for the ethical
treatment of animals
an ironically named group because they
actually kill a lot of animals they are
involved in the killing of animals but
that's
neither here nor there because there
aren't enough people to take care of
them anyway neither here nor there at
least for this ad the people for the
ethical treatment of animals are i just
put out a video
the video was trying to persuade people
that if you go vegan you'll have a
better sex life it's better for your you
know blood flow or whatever and so the
the video
involved i mean if you're you know we've
only got about a minute and a half left
here so if you've got
if you've got young children watching
listening is fine but watching uh maybe
close their eyes for a second
it's a video
of people molesting fruit
take a listen
that says wanna spice things up in the
bedroom people would like a kiwi and a
pepper chili peppers will have you hot
and heavy in no time the squirt of oj
can increase blood flow to important
organs
i'm going to look away from this get a
load of the zinc to increase your libido
avocados well this is disgusting we'll
give you the stamina to keep going go
vegan your partner will thank you
[Music]
molesting a cantaloupe and now someone
lay this just stop it stop it stop it
turn it off
this uh
this is the values that we're looking at
now first of all it's not very
persuasive to me
when we're told to adopt the you know
adopt our ethical system
and we're being told that by people who
are molesting fruit i don't that doesn't
seem like i want to adopt their ethical
system but this is a lot this actually
has to do with the political strategy of
the left what the left is doing they
always make these jokes like well if you
oppose our reviews you probably don't
have enough sex you're an in-cell or you
have small genitalia or you don't get
you pick up enough chicks or you don't
or you're not i don't know whatever it's
all like it always comes down to sex and
the reason they do this
is because their view of liberty is one
of of licentiousness and it just comes
down to lust and you know
whoever you can sleep with and just
doing a bunch of weird sex stuff to
appease your own appetites that's their
view i mean that's what they do they
enslave people by
by enslaving them to their own lusts and
getting them out of their rational mind
so that they can think that a video of
someone molesting fruit is somehow
persuasive what we are looking for is a
higher form of liberty okay and that's a
lot different that you're not going to
get to that exalted spirit of freedom
that edmund burke talked about if you
are
merely some egghead idiot looking at a
spreadsheet and making some craving
calculations
listen to nancy pelosi
please take notes
you've got to talk about values you've
got to talk about justice you've got to
talk about true and false and right and
wrong otherwise we're all going to end
up like liz cheney i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
today on the ben shapiro show this week
marks three big budgetary issues for joe
biden he's got a problem on every single
one of them plus joe biden continues to
slander border patrol that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen